okay in sign language which is an
acronym comprising of the following
toxic traits which is shame insults
guilt and a need to be right against
their opponent when they themselves
can't present a cogent argument based in
facts statistics or logic this debating
tactic is called sign language here we
will Define discuss and give an example
of each word that makes up the acronym
Shame Shame which is defined as a person
action or situation that makes someone
feel ashamed shame can cause someone to
feel inadequate and often leave them
with a painful sense of humiliation or
distress caused by another person's
abusive words for example who hurt you
insult insult is defined as a
disrespectful or scornfully abusive
remark or action criticizing someone is
an easy target especially if they know
how to hurt that person and often attack
the person where they can feel most
vulnerable whether it's bashing
someone's appearance accomplishment
capturing skills self-worth or financial
worth just to name a few for example
you'll hear things like you're just
bitter or you don't make enough money to
be with me
guilt the definition of guilt is to make
someone feel guilty especially in order
to induce them to do something making
someone feel like they are not doing
what they are hardwired to do is a
highly effective while toxic and
damaging attack that is often used for
example you obviously hate all women
including your mother or you obviously
hate all men including your dad The Need
to Be Right most people have a need to
be right whatever they say they want it
to be true and for other people to
accept it as being true at the very
least they want to avoid appearing wrong
you will often hear someone refer back
to a real or perceived slight that took
place many years before and may or even
may not be related to the altercation at
hand for example you don't know what
you're talking about because you're just
a simple man or you're not grasping what
I'm trying to tell you because you are
not listening to me
now here's some real live examples of it
so what else you do outside this uh
[Music]
the job
that's what I do I mean I'm working on a
business also
[Music]
working on the business yeah I'm working
on a business I'm working on my business
or you trying to get in my business I
mean I'm working on the business I mean
I we may actually make good money now I
get the bills paid I have spending but I
guess you know
the title like food you know like you
know
so what do you think I got a house in
there using that a two-bedroom
a two-bedroom
[Music]
what is the rest of the house
it's a two-bedroom man it's not like
it's 30 people stay with me I mean it's
a nice I don't stay with nobody I own a
room my body that was coming in and out
the house and it was mine I'm
independent like what's the problem I
gotta I got a house gotta call I got a
job what's the problem
you is I'm interviewing you I ain't got
time to witness other people trying to
fill the same position I mean I'm just
trying to get to know you like so you
got yours
you won yeah a whole child
oh I don't understand too many that's
one way too many
more absolutely not oh is that a is that
a first date
but I think we kind of hush get the gist
because doing the show for how long I'm
sure you've seen sign language I've seen
sign language many times and even online
um when I you know post videos or go
into the comment section one of the
major things when it comes to silent
when sign language women say
you're hurt you hurt you who hurt you
who hurt you why are you saying this and
normally it is a rebuttal to factual
information okay
um no not arguably respect your
information they said that to me all the
time as well they said then I was just
bitter look at who hurt you now look at
that but if we if we really do break it
down we understand the manosphere in a
Red Bull space when men are speaking
about things like either divorce
right where men get you know shafted in
divorces or you know suicide rates
amongst men or the way in which you know
women treat men in this day and time
with their hopeless Andrea one of the
major rebuttals that I found is that
women say oh who hurt you you're hurt
so my question is
why is that the rebuttal
are you asking me yeah I'm asking you to
never
um well I don't usually say that but
usually when you're talking about who
hurts you may be like who's making a
trip like why are you acting up is it
because your brethrons are doing better
than you making you feel better about
yourself or is it maybe there was a girl
that came into your life one day and
broke your heart is making you add some
type of way towards everybody else I
think that's where it comes from even
though I don't really say that to people
but you've had it though right
you've heard women say that in regards
to men yeah yeah actually I've said it
before still I was gonna say I've heard
you say it okay I was about to say I've
heard that say it but why why is that
the rebuttal when they hear um factual
information on Auntie do you think I
think it's just a fight but just to try
and embarrass people or to make them
feel shame rather than that is just the
way it is it's that's the first one they
come back with like who hurt you no
nobody's hurt me this is just the way I
am this is just the way it is this is
just the way I feel why does somebody
have to hurt me for me to express myself
just because I'm a man
I think if it was how many times as a
woman say to another woman who hurt you
see exactly and they're more damage than
anybody else the women it's not me then
the ones that get hurt not the men but
the first thing they say to me is who
hurt you but I've never heard a woman
say to another woman who hurt you
I think there's two sides to that you
know I feel like a lot of the time we
speak from experience or things that
we've been through so if you're
triggered and you're projecting and
having a moment I feel when people say
that but then there is the other side
because I've been in the position before
if someone's saying something that you
feel like you can relate to or you've
done and you're like the Panic is like
oh who hurt you because you know that
maybe you've displayed that behavior or
that thing before but I think there's
two I think the issue is it's difficult
to be able to separate those who are
saying who hurt you as an robot or
because they have nothing else to say to
the facts that are being presented by
the same time I do feel like we all come
from relative trauma paid experiences so
sometimes our passion can come across
misleading so you might have a fact but
the way in which you're expressing
yourself is like okay
I get that you're passionate about this
but maybe you're not speaking directly
to me you're speaking from a place of
her where did I come from but I can
definitely understand why a man would
fall out okay now that I'm speaking
facts are suddenly who hurt you but
generally like why why are you coming
across so aggressive like just you know
the thing is with that I've always said
like
with we're all sitting on this panel
right we've all been hurt to some degree
right all of us have had a heartbreak
right right and both men and women I'm
immune everybody
pounds immune to heartbreak but I'm
saying generally a lot of women have had
a heartbreak yeah but when I'm when a
woman speaks
her truth or whatever it is a man's
rebuttal to the woman's argument is not
who hurt you
but a woman's rebuttal to a man's
argument would be who hurt you that's
fingers anytime a Man shows a bit of
emotion that they honestly believe that
because he's showing a bit of emotion
they must be showing it just because
they've got hurt now they're doing it
because they've got feelings they're
when I get all that is you're insecure
you're insecure insecure yeah yeah but
does that separate because the thing is
you
you can have an opinion and you can also
at the same time seem insecure like
those things can close this at the same
time and I can understand that it's
frustrating when you're trying to have a
conversation that's supposed to be
Progressive that someone only highlights
the insecurity but right ultimately I'm
highlighting what I'm seeing and that's
not immediately a problem
even though it's not immediately
Progressive for that conversation but
the thing is do you hurt you in my
personal experience from what I've
experienced is used to deflect
it's a deflection tactic yeah
to uh to not actually deal with what is
actually being said it's the same thing
with urine secure it's the same thing
with you're insecure yeah then it's like
honestly modern women have like a A
system that they go through yeah it
usually starts with like who hurt you um
then it goes to your insecure then they
might attack something about your looks
or incision and if it's a guy like if to
me they usually go for like my style or
like the way I look something like that
you're white yeah yeah but if they don't
do that if it's a guy they might go for
his money say insinuate he has a small
or like say he can't get girls
yeah sometimes yeah
um and then if that doesn't work they'll
maybe say you need therapy that's a
common one yeah
um smooth energy yeah I've got small
dick energy
there are stereotypes to everything and
again we it's fair to say that these are
all deflections but they are real things
and I think when we're speaking up
specifically women who are you know
thrown out these um these statements
these are people that perhaps are not
used to being in a situations where men
can articulate themselves or show an
emotion we're not how do you deal with
that you're probably used to men who
shut down and walk away so now that
you're in a situation where somebody's
actually giving you the opportunity to
communicate the only thing you're able
to say is that your buyers anyway you're
like oh
Butters anyways
do you know what I think you're dead
anyways you get it shut Up Bones
actually I actually think women have a
hard time with hearing the truth about
themselves I agree and so when you have
a hard time hearing the truth about
yourself your instant reaction is to
attack back because you feel attacked
yeah and it may not generally be an
attack the most the most I've ever been
attacked is when I said men don't like
fat chicks right I swear to God exactly
and like I don't make the rules I'm just
saying by and large they don't and the
street did the Jamaica
yeah
they might like they might like a fat
ass and big boobs but they don't no guy
wants to go they like big butts they
like curvy not fat as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible